[Music]
the ancient city of mohenjo-daro is one
of the first urban centers in human
history nestled in southern Pakistan's
Indus River Valley mohenjo-daro is the
largest and best-preserved city of the
Indus civilization the earliest known
civilization of the Indian subcontinent
mohenjo-daro was built around 2500 BC
about the same time the great pyramids
were being built in Egypt and expand a
surface area of nearly 500 acres an
incredible size for a city of this time
period because of mohenjo-daro s grand
scale archeologists believe it may have
served as a seat of power for the Indus
civilization the city was divided into
two districts the Citadel and the Lower
Town the Citadel is home to the city's
exceptional monuments including the
great baths a 900 square foot tank fed
from the Indus River mohenjo-daro also
had a sophisticated water system houses
had baths and toilets and the town
featured both an elaborate sewage system
and fresh water and 700 wells throughout
the city the Roman baths some of
history's most famous waterway systems
weren't constructed until many hundreds
of years after mohenjo-daro scrape baths
mohenjo-daro has no places of worship or
governance such as palaces royal tombs
or temples this may indicate that the
society was not built around state
interests like the Egyptian and
Mesopotamian societies at the time
rather the class structure of
mohenjo-daro may have been relatively
equal the city's second district the
Lower Town may demonstrate the societies
egalitarian structure the Lower Town
with its intricate water system was home
to between 20,000 to 40,000 people
unlike many urban areas of its time it
was laid out in a grid system similar to
modern-day city blocks
after approximately 600 years the city
collapsed no one is quite sure why but
the cause could potentially have been a
change within the culture or in the path
of the river without its crucial source
of water the city's residents may have
moved away leaving mohenjo-daro nearly
abandoned in 1911 nearly 4,000 years
after the city fell into ruin
archeologists paid their first visit the
ensuing decades of excavations have
unearthed countless clues that tell the
tale of mohenjo-daro but it still holds
secrets for us to discover
[Music]